GREG GUTFELD, AND JUAN WILLIAMS.
IT’S 5:00 IN NEW YORK, AND THIS
IS "THE FIVE."
THE BATTLE FOR 2020 OFFICIALLY
KICKS OFF WITH THE IOWA CAUCUSES
JUST A FEW HOURS FROM NOW.
THE HAWKEYE STATE COULD PROVE TO
BE A PIVOTAL MOMENT IN THE
DEMOCRATIC RACE.
THE PARTIES ’ESTABLISHMENT
BRACING FOR A BERNIE SANDERS
SURGE WHILE SLEEPY JOE’S ALLIES
ARE PREPARING FOR THE WORST.
HERE IS THE TOP CANDIDATES
MAKING THEIR FINAL PITCHES.
>> HAPPY CAUCUS DAY!
>> YOU ARE PART OF AN ABSOLUTE
FOR SWEEPING TO THE STATE OF
IOWA RIGHT NOW.
>> FEELING GOOD.
A LOT OF ENERGY, ENTHUSIASM,
BEEN TO A LOT OF COUNTIES ALL
OVER THE COUNTY, ALL OVER THE
STATE, AND IT FEELS GOOD.
>> AGREED TO DO PHONE CALLS,
KNOCK ON DOORS.
>> TOMORROW NIGHT IS THE
BEGINNING.
IT IS THE BEGINNING OF THE END
FOR DONALD TRUMP.
>> WHILE DEMOCRATS BATTLE IT OUT
AND I WELCOME THE TRUMP
CONTINUES TO STEAL THE
SPOTLIGHT.
THERE IS GROWING CONCERN AMONG
THE PARTY THAT 2020 CANDIDATES
DON’T STAND A CHANCE AGAINST
TRUMP, ESPECIALLY WHEN FACING
ATTACKS LIKE THESE.
>> I I HAVE LITTLE NICKNAMES FOR
ALL OF THEM, BUT --
>> I’M SURE THEY LOVE YOUR
NICKNAMES.
>> BUT THEY ARE ACCURATE.
>> LET’S START WITH JOE BIDEN.
>> I JUST THINK HE’S SLEEPY.
I WATCH HIM.
SLEEPY JOE.
>> HUNTER BIDEN.
>> WHERE IS HUNTER BIDEN DELMA?
>> BERNIE SANDERS.
>> I THINK HE’S A COMMUNIST.
YOU MENTIONED ELIZABETH WARREN,
A CALLER -- I THINK SHE’S A
FAIRY TALE.
>> Jesse: WHERE DO YOU SEE THE
ENERGY LEADING TO IF HE CAN GIVE
US A SENSE OF THAT?
SPEAK TO THE POLLS
AND A LOT
>> Juan: THE POLLS AND A LOT
OF PEOPLE ARE SAYING THEY SEE
BERNIE SANDERS COME OUT.
IT’S BY 3-5 POINTS AT BEST AND
YOU’LL SEE JOB I BIDEN RIGHT
THERE.
AND BEHIND THAT YOU GET PETE
BUTTIGIEG COMING IN, MAY BE A
LITTLE FURTHER DOWN.
AND THE QUESTIONS OF THE NIGHT
HAVE TO DO WITH A B CLUB CHAR,
THE SENATOR FROM NEIGHBORING
MINNESOTA, HOW WILL SHE DO?
I WAS SURPRISED TO HEAR THIS
ABOUT ELIZABETH WARREN.
HE LIVED WITH WARREN FROM
MASSACHUSETTS.
BUT AS YOU KNOW, SHE FOR A WHILE
HAD REALLY SURGE AND NOW IT
LOOKS LIKE THIS IS
BERNIE SANDERS’ SURGE AT JUST
THE RIGHT MOMENT AND IT COULD BE
CRUSHING FOR ELIZABETH WARREN.
JESSE CALLED AND SHE HAD
MEDICARE FOR ALL PROBLEM, DANA.
>> Jesse: SHE WAS OUT OF
COMMISSION AND PLAYED THE VICTIM
CARD AGAINST BERNIE AND SHE’S
LOOKING LIKE SHE’S TAILING OFF.
DO YOU AGREE WITH JUAN, IT’S A
TWO-PERSON RACE NOW IN IOWA
BETWEEN BIDEN AND BERNIE?
>> Dana: I THINK ALL OF US WHO
KNOW WHAT’S GOING TO HAPPEN
TONIGHT AND WE DON’T.
THE RULES OF CHANGE THE LAST
TIME AROUND.
A NEW THRESHOLD YOU HAVE TO HIT,
IT’S 15% AND THEN IT GOES TO A
SECOND BOUT OF ALIGNMENT AND
IT’S A LITTLE BIT CONFUSING.
I THINK THE END RESULT COULD BE
FAIRLY MUDDLED AND YOU COULD SEE
BERNIE SANDERS DO QUITE WELL.
I THINK MAYOR PETE OR EVEN
ANDREW YANG COULD DO WELL HERE
BUT DO NOT FORGET AMY CLUB
CHAR WHO CAMPAIGNED REALLY HARD
IN THE RURAL AREAS.
FOR LIZ WARREN, IF SHE DOESN’T
DO WELL HERE AND BERNIE SANDERS
DOES, AND HE GOES TO
NEW HAMPSHIRE THE KING AGAIN,
IT’LL BE INTERESTING TO SEE WHAT
SHE CONTINUES TO DO.
WILL SHE CONTINUE OR GET BEHIND
HIM?
>> Jesse: IF YOU ARE RUNNING
AGAINST BERNIE SANDERS, YOU
ALREADY SAID YOU’LL RAISE TAXES
ON THE MIDDLE TAX DOWN THAT
CLASS.
CAN I RAISE A SOUND BITE ON ONE
OF YOUR FAVORITE PEOPLE?
CHRIS MATTHEWS ON THE MISSING
BC, THIS IS HIS INTERPRETATION
OF THE FIELD.
>> I’M NOT HAPPY WITH THIS
FIELD.
I THINK THEY GOT TO FIND A
CANDIDATE FOR PRESIDENT WHO CAN
BEAT TRUMP.
>> DO YOU THINK ANYBODY IN THIS
COULD BEAT --
>> I’M STILL LOOKING.
>> Katie: I WAS THINKING OF
ALL THE PEOPLE WHO DIDN’T MAKE
IT TO THE IOWA CAUCUSES.
BETO WAS SUPPOSED TO BE THE NEXT
OBAMA.
KAMALA HARRIS KEPT SAYING I’M
GOING TO MOVE TO IOWA, THAT DID
NOT HAPPEN.
POLLING IS NOTORIOUSLY DIFFICULT
IN IOWA, BUT BERNIE SANDERS HAS
BEEN HERE BEFORE AND HE DOESN’T
WANT TO LOSE AGAIN SO HE’S BEEN
ABLE TO LEARN FOR MAYBE SOME OF
THE MISTAKES OR THE THINGS THEY
DID THAT TO DO LAST TIME AND
REALLY GET OUT THERE AND KNOCK
ON SOME DOORS.
TWO ELIZABETH WARREN, IF SHE
DOES NOT DO WELL, SHE’LL
PROBABLY DROP OUT.
JOE BIDEN, THEY BEEN SAYING
FOREVER THAT IT DOESN’T MATTER
IF HE WINS IOWA WELCOME IT
DOESN’T MATTER IF HE WINS
NEW HAMPSHIRE.
THEY ARE BASING SOUTH CAROLINA
TO GET HIM THROUGH.
INTERESTING STRATEGY AND THERE
ARE EXCUSES FOR LOSING IF HE
DOES TONIGHT WILL BE INTERESTING
INTERESTING.
>> Jesse:>> Jesse: SETTING EXCIT
PRETTY LOW.
GREG, I KNOW YOU ARE GOING TO BE
WATCHING THE CAUCUSES TONIGHT.
>> Greg: LIKE A HAWK.
LIKE A HAWKCUS.
YOU ARE WELCOME TO AMERICA, A
DAY AFTER THE SUPER BOWL WHERE
50% OF "THE FIVE" ARE HUNG OVER.
UNLIKE 50 MILLION PEOPLE AT WORK
WHO DON’T SHOW UP BECAUSE WE
LOVE YOU.
TRYING TO MAKE IT THROUGH
WITHOUT VOMITING ON JESSE’S NICE
SUIT.
A LOT OF INTERESTING PEOPLE ARE
NOT RUNNING.
THEY ARE NOT PARTICIPATING.
SO THIS CRUISE SEEMS VERY WEAK
AND BLAND.
IT REMINDS ME -- WHEN YOU ARE A
KID AND YEAR PARENTS BOUGHT THAT
VARIETY SET OF BREAKFAST CEREAL?
THOSE ARE GREAT.
BY THE END OF THE FIRST WEEK,
ALL THAT WAS LEFT WAS SPECIAL K
AND BRAN FLAKES.
ALWAYS SPECIAL K, RIGHT?
WEIRD BOX.
THE PROBLEM WITH THIS FIELD,
IT’S ALL BRAN FLAKES AND SPECIAL
K.
ESPECIALLY MAYOR PETE.
YOU KNOW, MAYOR PETE IS GREAT
WHEN HE’S AROUND OTHERS BECAUSE
HE SEEMS INTERESTING.
HE’S LIKE A GREAT SECONDARY
CHARACTER IN A TV SHOW.
BUT WHEN THEY DECIDE TO SPIN HIM
OFF, HE IS A FLOP?
YOU REMEMBER HOW MUCH YOU LOVE
JOEY AND FRIENDS.
HE WAS GREAT.
BUT YOU DIDN’T WATCH "JOEY."
IT WASN’T THE SAME WITHOUT
RACHEL, ROSS.
WITHOUT OTHER PEOPLE TO COMPARE
THEM TO, IT’S NOT GOING TO
HAPPEN.
AS FOR BERNIE, WE’VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT BERNIE FOR A LONG
TIME AND I CALL THIS THE
PENDULUM.
THE POPULACE AND FREIGHTER THAT
TOOK OVER 2016 IS NOW SWINGING
BACK TO THE LEFT.
ALL THESE THINGS ARE CYCLICAL.
WE HAVE THE POPULIST INFERNO
THAT BROUGHT IN TROUBLE, THE
SAME MENTALITY COULD BRING
BERNIE IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
WHEN I SHARE THIS SENTIMENT WITH
CHRIS MATTHEWS, THAT COULD NEVER
HAPPEN?
I SAID THAT ABOUT TRUMP.
I SHOULD HAVE LISTENED --
NEVER MIND...
>> Jesse: YOU ARE VERY GOOD
THE DAY AFTER THE SUPER BOWL.
>> Greg: I’M CRYING INSIDE.
>> Jesse: I DISAGREE WITH YOU
ON ONE THING.
THE NEVER BERNIE MOVEMENT IS TEN
TIMES STRONGER THAN THE NEVER
TRUMP MOVEMENT.
AND YOU CAN SEE THE NEVER BERNIE
MOVEMENT ALREADY PULLING OUT ALL
THE STOPS WITH REINVIGORATING
THE POWER OF THE SUPERDELEGATES,
LETTING THE RULES CHANGE SO
BLOOMBERG CAN COME IN, HILLARY
COMING OUT OF NOWHERE TO DROP
BOMBS ON BERNIE.
I THINK BERNIE HAS A LOT COMING
IF YOU WINS IOWA, NEW HAMPSHIRE.
>> Katie: DO NOT KNOW IF YOU
CAN HEAR ME, JESSE, I THINK
THAT’S VERY TRUE.
IT’S NOT ABOUT A DIFFERENCE IN
STYLE OR DIFFERENCE IN RHETORIC
OR DEMETER OR CIVILITY.
IT’S A COMPLETELY DEPARTURE FROM
A LOT OF THINGS WE HOLD DEAR AND
AMERICA.
FROM A POLICY STANDPOINT, THE
ENTHUSIASM FOR A BERNIE
CANDIDACY, HE’LL HAVE HIS PEOPLE
AND HE’LL HAVE THE 40% BUT I DO
NOT THINK THE REST OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY WILL
ENTHUSIASTICALLY GET BEHIND HIM.
>> Juan: SAW WHAT HAPPENED IN
2016, THE REPUBLICAN
ESTABLISHMENT WAS SO ANTI-TRUMP
AND DID NOT THINK TRUMP COULD
BEAT THE DEMOCRATS.
>> Dana: THAT WAS A LOT MORE
ABOUT STYLE THAN POLICY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP AS A CANDIDATE
WASN’T TALKING ABOUT A WHOLE SO
DEPARTURE OF THE AMERICAN WAY OF
LIFE.
>> Jesse: RIGHT AND I STILL